بينما في نجم النجوم
كريستيانو رونالدو وواحد من
أعظم اللاعبين الذين رأيناهم على الإطلاق
قضى موسمًا رائعًا مع ريال
مدريد في ترك رئيس
النادي هدافيهم برصيد 16 هدفًا في 11 مباراة
أخطأت في تسجيل رقمه القياسي في
الفوز بالمسابقة  إنه شامب هو
استغلال ركلة الجزاء الحاسمة ، أعتقد
أنه سيكون واثقًا من
دخوله البطولة ، فهو أفضل لاعب ،
حيث مثل اللاتينية إبراهيموفيتش ، موسم رائع
من شارع الخوف متحمسًا
للتأهل إلى السويد ، ومن الواضح أنه
سيكون وكيلاً حرًا.
لإظهار قدرته على التفكير في أن جاريث
بيل مع ويلز من الواضح أنه ليس من
المرشحين لكن وجوده تحت تصرفهم
أعتقد أن الثرثار سيكون أحد
لاعبي البطولة
وأعتقد أن أنطوان جريزمان يحمل
الكثير من التوقعات  فرنسا
موسم رائع لابتلاع الكرة
لأتليتكو مدريد ، سيقود خط فر
سا وأعتقد أنه سيكون هناك الكثير من ال
جوم في هذه المسرحية المهم أيضًا أن
لقد كانوا يدعمون بسرعة وأنت تعلم أن
تقديم الخدمة لبعض هؤلاء
اللاعبين الكبار لتسجيل أهدافهم
في ألمانيا لن يكونوا مفضلين
من حيث الظهور عندما تمشي ،
أعتقد أنه يمكنك أن تعيش السباحة
مهم للغاية لإيجاد التوازن في ذلك
فريق لديهم بعض المشكلات الدفاعية في
الوقت الحالي ، لكن أعتقد أن ألمانيا هي
الفريق النهائي الذي لا يملكون نجومًا ، كما
يقول بعض البلدان الأخرى
مثل فرنسا وربما بلجيكا ،
لكن فريقهم هو أعظم
رصيد لهم
، وأعتقد أن إسبانيا كما تعلم.
كرة قدم داخلية ، لقد غيروا اللعبة نوعًا ما
وفوزوا في البطولات ، ثم
هناك فرنسا ، الأمة بأكملها ،
دعمك وراءهم عاطفياً ،
أعتقد أنهم محظوظون
لأن لديهم مدربًا رائعًا في ديدييه ،
مشجعو كاثرين شون بول الذي يفهم
توقع التعامل مع المناسبة
أعتقد أنه سيكون قادرًا على إيجاد المزيج المناسب
والحصول على هذا الدعم المنزلي
واللاعبين النجوم الآخرين
أعتقد أن فرنسا هي الفريق الذي  إذا تمكنوا
من الحصول على بعض هؤلاء اللاعبين المصابين
في الظهير ، فلن يتمتعوا بصحة جيدة